the demon king has loomed large over the
story of the seven deadly sins for a
very long time he is the father of
meliora sans el dress he is the ruler of
the entire demon clan and his power
reaches divine levels but just as
interesting as the demon Kings power are
his true thoughts feelings and
motivations why does the demon king do
all of the terrible things that he has
done and why does he treat even his own
sons with such condescension and
contempt I am Anna Mac for anime uproar
and in this video we are going to take a
deep dive into the psyche of the demon
king in order to understand what makes
him tick what motivates him to do the
evil things that he has done and what
his psychological profile tells us about
what to expect from him in the future I
hope to make this type of video into a
series in which I explore the psychology
of other mysterious and ominous anime
characters so if that's something that
you want to see the best way to let me
know is to like the video and share it
with anyone who might be interested also
to subscribe to the channel and hit that
notification bell and to show your
support down in the comments feel free
to let me know which other fictional
characters and their psychological
profiles you would like me to examine in
the future now in order to fully
understand the mind of the demon king I
will have to analyze all the available
information up to this point including
information from the manga with that
said this video will contain manga
spoilers so please proceed with caution
if we were to build a criminal profile
of the demon king we would have to
classify him as a highly organized and
intelligent offender as far as we know
he is the oldest known creature in the
seven deadly sins especially if we take
the time he spent in purgatory into
consideration and some of the plans that
the demon king has set in motion took
thousands of years to come to fruition
this tells us that the demon king is
extremely cunning a meticulous planner
and both patient
and determined the demon king is able to
predict the behavior of others and
manipulate them using both his
intelligence and his incredible magical
abilities we know how powerful the demon
king is for a long time we've been told
that he and the supreme deity are the
two most powerful creatures in that
entire magical world and we've even seen
the demon Kings opie abilities in action
if you want to know more about the demon
Kings power you can check out our video
called how strong is the demon king I
will link it in the description so feel
free to watch that right after this but
what about the demon king psychology why
does he do the things that he has done
as we have seen for the demon king
loyalty is paramount there is nothing
that he hates more than weakness and
disloyalty and as the ruler of the demon
clan he cannot understand why anyone
would betray the interests of the demon
clan as a whole because of some personal
feelings or connections the demon king
is even prepared to severely punish his
own sons when he believes they are
acting out of weakness and disloyalty
and it wouldn't be hard to argue that
the curse which the demon king has
placed on his eldest son meliodas
is a fate worse than death meliodas was
cursed so that he cannot die and so he
must relive the pain of losing the woman
he loves over and over again for
thousands of years but this hate that
the demon king feels about the very idea
of betrayal actually reveals a lot about
his personality clearly the demon king
has serious trust issues he doesn't
trust anyone and he values power and
control above all other things
the reason he values power and control
is likely because being completely in
control reduces the chances of someone
betraying you or stabbing you in the
back we know that in the past the demon
king has been betrayed first the
original demon betrayed him the demon
king used a large portion of his own
power to create the original demon and
the idea was that the original demon
would help the demon king rule over the
tumultuous demon realm a more
effectively however the original demon
betrayed the demon king and attempted to
overthrow him ultimately the original
demons rebellion failed and the demon
king punished him by splitting him up
into two death
beings and then tasking those beings
with training the demon Kings two sons
but there is a lot more to this than
merely summarizing the events very
briefly as I just did the demon king
would have been affected psychologically
by this betrayal the original demon of
being that he himself created and a
being that he trusted stabbed the demon
king in the back and nearly overthrew
him this type of traumatic event would
definitely make you think twice about
trusting someone again especially when
you are the ruler of an entire clan and
you possess the kind of power that
others would certainly want to take for
themselves if they could and after this
came the betrayal of Mele Otis his
eldest son and heir to the throne as the
ruler of the demon clan the demon king
has to put the interests of the clan as
a whole or at least what he believes to
be the interest of the clan as a whole
ahead of personal interests of
individuals the demons and the other
clans and especially the goddess clan
had been at war for a very long time and
as evil as the demon king appears to us
right now we have to remember that the
goddess clan teaches its members from a
very young age that all demons are
impure and vile creatures and that they
all need to be exterminated so it's not
like the goddesses want peace and the
demon king wants to destroy them the
goddesses are a real and serious threat
to the very existence of the demon clan
the demon king saw his oldest son
meliodas as his heir meliodas was known
as a ruthless and loyal demon Prince and
he had unrivaled potential as such
meliodas was the obvious choice for the
next demon king the one who would
destroy the enemies of the demons before
those enemies could destroy them however
Mele Otis ultimately fell in love with
Elizabeth a member of the goddess clan
and because he no longer supported the
holy war he betrayed the demon clan and
abandoned the ten commandments the elite
demon fighting force of which he was a
part it is believed that Mele Otis even
killed the two members of the
commandments during his betrayal and
this represents the second time that the
demon king had someone close to him
betray him and stab him in the back
first the original demon of being he
created and then his own son his heir
apparent it isn't hard to see how these
two betrayals and perhaps
other portrayals that we don't even know
about would lead the demon king to
having severe trust issues in fact the
demon king hates being deceived so much
that he destroyed the entire city of
beli Alwyn together with the supreme
deity after the two of them had been
deceived by Merlin we can assume that
because he was deceived and betrayed so
many times including by people closest
to him the demon king has come to see
all emotions and especially the emotion
of love as a weakness you can only be
betrayed by someone close to you if you
allow someone to be close to you in the
first place and so the demon king likely
concluded that being attached to anyone
including his own sons is a weakness the
demon king most likely concluded that if
he simply lets go of all of his emotions
all personal attachments and all ideas
of trust and love he could protect
himself from ever being betrayed again
this is one of the reasons why the demon
king behaves so ruthlessly and why he
taunts malleolus and celtris about the
fact that their love for Elizabeth and
gelda affect their judgment his loathing
for Elizabeth in particular really comes
out once he takes possession of
melioidosis body and confronts her face
to face he even says that he will remove
her curse just so he can brutally kill
her and this is because for the demon
king elizabeth is the very embodiment of
his son's weakness and of his son's
betrayal there may also be some other
factors at play here perhaps the demon
king was also betrayed by a woman at
some point maybe even the supreme deity
and that is why he has a special dislike
for Elizabeth and for her relationship
with meliodas but that is all just
speculation at this time but there is
one other important factor that we have
to consider in order to get a more
complete picture of the demon Kings mind
the fact that the demon king is a king a
ruler complicates his state of mind and
motivations because the duties and
responsibilities of a ruler are
different than those of an ordinary
person the demon king is believed to be
the first king of the demon clan and
assuming that this is indeed the case at
some point the demon king would have had
to have taken control of the chaotic
demon realm and bring order to it he
would have had to not only unite the
entire demon realm which is home to some
incredibly powerful creatures but at the
same time he would also have had to deal
with external
threats like potential attacks by the
goddess clan so the demon king isn't
only worried about his personal
relationships and family ties he has to
also worry about gaining control of the
demon realm and crushing all internal
threats while also dealing with serious
external threats posed by rival clans we
already know that during this process
the demon king was betrayed by people he
trusted including the original demon and
so no matter what we think of the demon
king now we have to assume that he went
through a lot of hardship before he got
to where he is today including the types
of hardship that an ordinary person who
doesn't have responsibility of ruling
over others will never have to worry
about looking at some real world
examples from our own history can help
shed light on how the demon king became
who he is today
Qin Shi Huangdi the first emperor of
China and Tokugawa Ieyasu the founder of
the Tokugawa Shogunate in Japan are good
examples of real world rulers who had to
become ruthless in order to bring order
to a chaotic realm China before the rise
of the first emperor and Japan before
the Tokugawa Shogunate were extremely
divided realms where smaller warring
States and warlords were constantly
struggling for supremacy violence
suffering and death were daily
occurrences for centuries and
potentially hundreds of thousands of
innocent people were killed as a result
of the constant warfare although it is
impossible to know the true number of
casualties if you've seen the anime door
or oh then you will have some idea of
what Japan was like in the period before
the Tokugawa Shogunate was formed the
first emperor of China and the founder
of the Tokugawa Shogunate eventually
brought peace to their realms by
unifying the warring States and kingdoms
into one large realm under a single
ruler but they didn't achieve this
through rational arguments or trust and
kindness they succeeded because they
ruthlessly destroyed all rival factions
and eliminated all potential rivals
through the throne they achieved a noble
end they stopped the wars and the
suffering of so many people but they did
it by ruthlessly destroying all of their
enemies and we have to assume that the
demon king had to go through a similar
power struggle the demon realm which we
know was chaotic and unruly was likely
subjugated by the demon king and his
forces through some very brutal mean
and this power struggle likely played an
important role in shaping the demon
Kings personality he knows from
experience that you have to be ruthless
in order to bring order to chaos
he knows that you might have to face
betrayal along the way even from those
closest to you and he has shaped his
personality accordingly this doesn't
mean that we should support or excuse
the demon Kings behavior but all of this
does help us understand where he is
coming from and how he came to be who he
is today we've all heard the expression
it's lonely at the top as the ruler of
the demon clan the demon king is at the
top but with power comes betrayal and as
someone who has been betrayed multiple
times the demon king appears to be
incapable of trusting anyone and is even
somewhat paranoid in recent chapters we
learned that the demon king has been
using the power of the commandments to
keep track of all the commandments and
their actions and intentions and of
course we know that the demon king has
been using hawk and other creatures to
spy on meliodas for a long time even the
names of some of the demon Kings
recently revealed special abilities the
sighing sage and the Hermit of moments
seemed to allude to his profound
loneliness and seeing us how much time
he has spent in purgatory it makes sense
that the demon king would be extremely
lonely being a ruler who has to be
ruthless and who cannot trust anyone not
even those closest to him would make
anyone profoundly lonely and this
loneliness explains why the demon king
doesn't seem capable of empathizing with
anyone why he rejects all emotions as
weakness and why he mocks everyone who
doesn't look at the world in the same
way that he does finally the demon king
may actually resent his eldest son
meliodas because he may have an
inferiority complex in relation to his
son in more recent chapters we learned
that meliodas has an immense original
power a power so great that he has been
afraid to use it and a power that once
activated ensures that meliodas can no
longer remain in the mortal plane for
more than one day the demon king calls
this power the source of destruction and
it is possible that the demon king is
also afraid of melioidosis power and
potential after all the demon king is
the rule
the one who brought about order from
chaos at least within the demon clan and
I believe that the demon king fears
melioidosis immense potential to become
the destroyer their source of
destruction that brings an end to the
order that the demon king worked so hard
to build so while we can all agree that
the demon king is a villain and someone
who does bad things to innocent people
it is always important to try to
understand a character and where they
are coming from including villains a
good villain isn't evil for the sake of
being evil something made him the way he
is something drives him and his actions
when we examined the life of the demon
king we realized that he had to become
ruthless in order to bring order to
chaos inside the demon realm we realized
that he faced multiple betrayals by
people closest to him which led him to
reject trust and love while making him
lonely and paranoid and we realized that
the relationship between the demon king
and meliodas is a complex one because
Mele Otis's original power has the
potential to destroy everything that the
demon King worked all of his life to
build and I love how all of these
factors come together perfectly
in the epic showdown between the demon
king and meliodas in the seven deadly
sins manga I can't wait to see what
happens next and I really hope that you
enjoyed this journey inside the mind of
the demon king I hope that I've been
able to shed some light on his
personality and motivations and if this
video helped you get a better
understanding of the demon Kings
character you can leave a like to let me
know and you could subscribe for more
videos like this one if you want me to
make this into a series which explores
the mind of other anime characters you
can let me know by sharing this video
and giving me suggestions for which
characters to cover in the comments down
below if you feel that videos like this
one provide value for you and you want
to support more you can check out our
patreon we recently revamped the whole
thing a big thank you to all of the
patrons supporting us right now
including our pro hero tier patrons the
one and only Gilgamesh and keelon and
also are the one to your patrons the
ones who stand above all clans including
a seventeen FF DP lil lady KD and
daddy Mac 239 even donating a single
dollar will give you access to our
special patron only discord and you will
see your name appear in our videos so
please if you're interested check us out
link in the description as always thank
you guys so much for watching it means a
lot to me and until next time see us
bass cowboys
[Music]
you
[Music]